[Music]
both equally terrible does that settle
it stop pretending you know where you're
going I have a plan I just haven't told
you
[Music]
yet party for the move that's not good
what are those claws dude are you sure
you're even
Spider-Man are you who do you think you
are
really my name is mes Mor
[Music]
r i was bitten by a radio active
spider I'm pretty sure you know the rest
[Music]
jerk what's up
man you don't get it you're in anomal if
you let me go home
[Music]
snit everywhere you go you're an
anomaly you're the original
anomaly the spider that gave you your
powers wasn't from your
dimension it was never supposed to fight
you
youel there's a world out there with no
Spider-Man to protect them because it
been you instead you're not supposed to
be Spider-Man no you're lying I'm
Spider-Man you're a
mistake if you hadn't been bit your
Peter Parker would have lived instead he
died saving you he would have stopped
the collider before it ever went off
spot wouldn't exist and none of this
would have happened and all this time I
have been the only one holding it all
together Miguel go easy out here you
don't belong here you never
did that's enough this isn't what we
talked
about you talked about
this you
knew you you all
knew I I didn't
know how to tell
you that's why you never came to see
me
miles it's for your own good who decides
that I'm not a kid Gwen that's exactly
what you are you're just a kid who has
no idea what he's
doing yeah well I did lure hundreds of
spider people away from your little
[Music]
clubhouse I guess you did plan this
out and I'm about to do
[Music]
this everyone keeps telling me how my
story is supposed to go nah I'm going to
do my own
thing who you talking to but I really
got to wrap this are you going to be a
while cuz I
can't
okay let's do this one last time my name
is Miles Morales I was bitten by a
radioactive spider and for the last year
and four months I've been Brooklyn's one
and only Spider-Man and things are going
great you can hurt
somebody catching all sorts of bad
guys no can't you just act like a
regular super villain so I can catch
you I designed my new suit with some fly
Ambiance down the side a May mooved to
Florida done I guess I the Jeopardy
endorse baby powder apologize for
endorsing baby powder I made a mistake
my mustache came in
mustache and out I made another mistake
been developing a new Twist on my Venom
thing w w
w
s how much longer can I keep lying about
who I really am I hear that new
Spider-Man is Puerto Rican no he seems
more Dominican to me I mean would they
get it if I told them we love you and
accept you even though you have L to
us maybe in some other
Universe sometimes I just wish I wasn't
the only
one I don't dwell on
you
[Music]
I miss my uncle sometimes my see exactly
what you're
doing even though he turned out to be
the
prowler I'm going try to do what he told
me going just keep going you're looking
at your text you understand this is the
fight of our lives right s sorry just
just a second man no no no no go ahead
take the call turn off your phone in a
movie theater if you don't turn it off
when you're fighting me oh in a minute
ah I wrote it all this one word that's
cute right the
youth that's
weird no sorry I just I really got to be
some there's bubbles now hold on
who I think this is going
great still bubbles on here you know I
think it's probably okay it we're
figuring it out finding our
rhythm
[Music]
hey where the come
from I don't think I want this costume
anymore almost there Mommy smile face is
this your
good that's the end of the
day I got you right
where so aggressive I'm Spider-Man no
one can take that away from me
unbelievable come back to your Nemesis
don't escape your costume's too tight in
the back by the way why are you saying
it like that you're not funny I don't
know been really fun cleaning up your
shocking Mess by the way what next
kingpins collider what are you guys
talking about none of your business nosy
we saved the Multiverse you left a whole
wide enough for guys like him to
randomly get shot into the wrong
dimension now I'm stuck putting
everybody back where they belong before
all of time and space collapses and
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
199999 the doctor strange sounds like he
maybe shouldn't practice medicine sorry
captain now
hey so you want me to handle this one
[Music]
or huh
okay
got Hammer
St lilac can you please you know nah you
got to say it first call for backup what
call for backup come on please just call
for yeah I already called her but I
enjoyed
that
[Music]
Spiderwoman me
too are you uh oh this we don't know the
sex yet my husband wants it to be a
surprise he's really corny but so H will
you adopt me what what guys can we focus
on the this fireing time of SP
please what about her no we could use
the help no is it cuz she called you
dark Garfield do you say anything but no
no yes why not you know why
enough of
this take a good look at the M
[Music]
fire don't let him
out he'll disrupt the
[Music]
cannon give it it's
go to the ground will you get
out Peter you don't have to stay behind
I can do it it's okay I've made up my
mind I'll put the goober in and take
over the beam after you're gone I'll
blow it up good luck
guys they know we're
here
nice to see you again
Peter C these guys are the
[Music]
P why is this always difficult where you
going
Peter any last words can I get a minute
to think about it you a pen goodbye
Peter
[Music]
Parker who that
that Miles
SP wow mil you're doing it on command
it's about time right
look who here figed it out I love you
I'm so proud of you do I want
kids oh yeah I forgot about
[Music]
her well that doesn't promising
no K
[Music]
me no sorry that's
cheating I got to get
[Music]
that hold up not so easy doing it on
your own
isn't I can't wait to kill one more
Spiderman
what
wson is this what you want man what are
you doing stay away
froma Messa Richard what are we doing
here I don't know richarda you know me
we're leaving now don't
go stay with me
please you're not stoping not k
I am stopping this right
now I need back
[Music]
up
the real Spiderman couldn't even beat
beat
me
you're you took my
vamping now I'm going to make sure
you'll never see yours
[Music]
again Dr Olivia
Octavius
[Music]
can I assume that your friends call you
doot my friends actually call me live my
enemies call me do I got this run who
are you talking
to I got it got it
[Music]
Peter I got it handle
buddy everything is
fine okay a little bit there you're
CH the moment that I'm losing the
fight all right let me tell you the
goodness we don't need the monitor
Peter you didn't tell me you had an
invisible friend could you give me that
back young man
Peter it's
proprietary
oh wow this would be a good time to turn
invisible yep okay not going to turn
invisible selecting a bagel act super
normal Spider-Man you know that's funny
I get that a lot hey
Spiderman what do you think you're going
hey got Bagel all right time to swing
just like I taught you when did you
teach me that I didn't it's a little
joke team Builder he hey
hey all right you ready of course I'm
not
ready I can't do this everybody knows
that the best way to learn is under
infest life ning
[Music]
pressure come on come on come
on
uh-oh
oh what are you doing down there I run
better than I swing you got to swing or
they'll cat you this is what you
wanted
[Music]
thank you boy H with your hips look
where you want it to hit spray your
shoulders don't forget to follow through
don't shoot off your back Foon let's
kill me then stop listening to me that's
the best idea you had all
day
[Music]
do it is double tap to release and Swip
it out again okay swi and release and
whip
release and release you're
an the
rhym
releas I got to say you're amazing man
we're a little team me as the teacher
who can still do it you as the student
who can do it just not as good I'm proud
of us is there something you want to say
to
me
[Music]
Peter what the who did
that
hey
guys
whoa Norman listen to
me Spider-Man I cannot let you open a
portal to another dimension Brooklyn is
not zoned for that
it's not after me is that Gooden Goblin
why won't you quit I don't know I guess
I like Brooklyn not been stuck into a
black hole I think I'm going to go that
Island mayy
not
no
what is this
[Music]
place
did you know your shoes are in
tied uh-huh this is a a onesie so I
don't really have to worry about
[Music]
it I thought I was the only one you're
like me I don't want to be I don't think
you have a choice
[Music]
kiddo